This question concerns the abstractions that is
available in Nucleus. Remember Nucleus is the microkernel
of Spring. And the question asks, what is
the difference between the primitives, or the abstractions
available in Nucleus, and Liedtke's prescription for
what a microkernel should look like? And these
are the features that I am talking about.
The first feature is the abstraction of threads,
second is interprocess communication, and the third is address space.
And what I want you to do is fill this table
in terms of, what are the abstractions that I have
mentioned here available in Nucleus
versus Liedtke's prescription for a microkernel